I do think we are at an inflection point
for brain-computer interfaces,
what I would call a Kitty Hawk moment.
And I think just as we saw
after the Wright brothers sent
that plane into the air,
we're gonna see an explosion
of advanced development
of these technologies.
Over the past few years,
the prospect of linking our
brains directly with computers
has given rise to the
beginnings of a new industry.
Dozens of startups are popping up,
creating products to help people
with mental and physical disabilities,
revolutionize the way we
interact with technology,
and even alter the
functioning of our own brains.
We essentially open the door to the access
of our minds by technology.
So we're talking about the
changing of foundations
of what it means to be human.
How did we get here?
How well does all this
stuff actually work?
And if this technology lives up
to its transformational
potential, are we ready for it?
So a brain-computer interface is a device
that interfaces the brain
with the outside world.
It could be a computer,
it could be a machine.
And these brain-computer
interfaces, or BCIs,
could be inserted inside the brain.
So those are invasive BCIs,
or they could be wearables
that you would wear
on the top of your head.
BCIs can record the activity of the brain,
the firing of individual neurons.
Obviously, if you take
information out of the brain,
you can in principle
decode what that means.
And just like there was a
transition in technology
from the PC to the smartphone,
it is possible, I would say likely,
that the next transition
will be from a device
that you have in your pocket
to a device that you have in your head.
If you've heard
of one brain-computer interface,
it's probably this one.
All right, welcome to the
Neuralink product demo.
I'm really excited to
show you what we've got.
I think it's gonna blow your mind.
When Elon speaks, we all listen,
that's just life in the 21st century.
But Neuralink and its competitors
didn't come out of nowhere.
They're built on decades
of work by neuroscientists
attempting to understand and interpret
what's going on in the brain.
One of those neuroscientists,
and a key player
in the development of BCIs, is
this guy, Dr. Leigh Hochberg.
I'm the director of the
BrainGate pilot clinical trials.
The BrainGate pilot clinical
trials are seeking to determine
the safety and feasibility
of allowing somebody
with paralysis to control
an external device
simply by thinking.
The origins of this field
can be traced easily back
to the late 1950s, early 1960s.
Dr. Robert Heath has implanted electrodes,
which cause no pain, in the
brains of these monkeys.
Researchers were placing single
electrodes into the brain
of animals in a research laboratory,
asking the fairly
straightforward question of,
"How does that neuron in
that part of the brain
relate to the control
of voluntary movement?
And then in the late 1990s,
here at Brown University,
John Donoghue, professor of neuroscience,
did an experiment in
the research laboratory,
which was to ask a non-human
primate to play a video game.
And the researchers begin to build a map
between the brain activity
and the movement of the hand.
After building that map,
that program would be able to predict
where the animal's hand
actually was in space.
You could then play a
small trick on the animal,
which is to disconnect the joystick.
And at that moment,
the joystick is no longer
controlling the cursor
on the screen,
the neural activity itself
is controlling the cursor movement.
So we begin to describe that as a cursor
that's moving under neural power alone.
And that was really a breakthrough moment.
Within a few years,
researchers were trying out
the same thing in humans.
So in the spring of 2004,
the BrainGate clinical
trials were launched.
The technology begins with a sensor,
or an array as we call it,
that's placed in the brain.
The sensor itself is about
four by four millimeters,
the size of a baby aspirin.
And when tapped into the top of the brain,
it has the ability to record
from individual neurons.
So that when somebody thinks
about moving their own hand,
we can allow them to control
a cursor on a computer screen
or some other assistive technology.
What do you want to do first?
[Study Participant] I'd
like to draw a circle.
You're gonna draw a circle?
Excellent.
That incredible first
participant was able to think
about opening and closing
a prosthetic hand.
And which was,
I think he said out loud what
everybody else was thinking.
The third participant was
an extraordinary woman
who had had a stroke in the brainstem.
She could feel everything,
she could hear everything,
but she couldn't move
and she couldn't speak.
And she said she wanted to take a drink.
So we brought in a robotic arm.
She was thinking about
reaching and grasping
that thermos of coffee.
As she did that, the robot arm moved out,
grabbed that thermos of coffee.
And then she took a sip of cinnamon latte
and that was the first
time in nearly 15 years
that she was able to do so
solely of her own volition.
Over the 17 years
of the BrainGate trials,
the technology has come a long way,
particularly as advances
in machine learning
have made strides helping to decode data
recorded from the brain.
Recently, they were even
able to have a paralyzed man
imagine the motion of handwriting
and translate that into text
on a screen with 94% accuracy.
But clinical trials in university labs,
they're really just a first step.
At some point there needs to
be an off-ramp to a company
who is then gonna focus
on developing what,
as an academic, a word that
I don't use that often,
to make a product.
It needs to be submitted
for regulatory approval
and then it needs to be
marketed and supported
and made available.
When we first started this company,
people almost kind of took this
as just kind of almost
crazy science fiction.
And I think we're getting
past the believability factor.
We're starting to see what
was originally kind of
research technology take
flight in the clinical domain.
And I think we're gonna
see many, many more
of these type of technologies.
Here in St. Louis,
a company called Neurolutions recently got
one of the first FDA
approvals ever for a BCI.
In this case, a noninvasive EEG headset
that reads the electrical
activity of the brain.
The measurements aren't as precise
as with an invasive system,
like the one BrainGate uses,
but they work for Neurolutions' purpose:
helping stroke victims
to reconnect their mind
with a paralyzed limb.
All right, so we're just gonna test
the headset real quick.
All connections good. Nice and relaxed.
My name's Mark Forrest.
I lived in St. Louis all my life
and turns out I had a stroke
and I was pretty much
paralyzed on my right side.
A lot of people told me after six months
that I was pretty much done
and I was gonna have hardly any movement.
When somebody has a stroke,
a part of their brain dies.
For instance, the right side is injured,
the left side can't move.
Now, but if you talk to these patients,
they can imagine moving.
They can try to move.
They just can't actually
execute that movement.
We know that 90% of those motor fibers
that control opening and closing
that hand are on that side
where the injury occurred.
What we found is that there's actually 10%
on the healthy side, on
the other side of the brain
that controls thought of,
"I want to move my hand."
And so what we did is,
we created a brain-computer interface
that really has three parts
to it: a wearable headset,
a robotic exoskeleton, and a
tablet that walks them through
how to use the system.
All right, let's see.
So let's do 30 seconds rest
and then I'm gonna hit Next
and we'll see what control you'll get.
At the beginning of the
program it'll tells you
not to move your hand,
but think about moving your hand,
and that's what you have to do.
Now just imagine.
It's picking up that intention to move
on the uninjured side of the brain.
It's converting that
intention to a movement
of the exoskeleton.
As the person continues
to use it over time,
it's essentially leading
to a rewiring of the brain.
There's this kind of neuroscience notion
of what fires together, wires together.
So when they're generating
those brain signals to move
and they're getting that
feedback from that wearable,
that's leading to new
connections forming in the brain
that allows, eventually, that
uninjured side of the brain
to take over control
of the paralyzed limb.
My movement was just this,
that's all I could do.
Look at how much difference
I've made - progressed,
using that machine.
I have arm movement. I
have finger movement.
I have wrist movement.
It got me motivated for,
I actually built my own fishing boat.
My eldest son said, it's gonna
sink. It's not gonna float.
My best friend told me it was gonna sink
and not gonna float.
Well, I've proved them all wrong.
The lord works in mysterious ways,
[expletive deleted]
happens and there's nothing
you can do about it.
So you just make it work.
Companies like Neurolutions
are bringing BCIs
into the realm of healthcare,
but that's kind of just
the tip of the iceberg.
Tech companies are starting
to get in on the action too
and they've got a whole
different set of uses in mind
for these technologies.
At the end of the day,
the only thing that a
computer or a smartphone does
is connect you to the 'net.
Well, with a BCI, you'll be able to do
this much faster and easier.
The leaders of Google and Facebook,
they expect in the future,
to be able to just
communicate directly with BCI.
In the future we want to get to an input
where we can just think
something and it happens.
And this also has
stimulated the generation
of many, many new companies,
neurotech companies,
probably more than 100
over the last year or so.
One of those companies
is French startup NextMind,
which is making a small wearable
that can detect the
firing of your neurons,
much like the Neurolutions headset.
And you can actually buy
one from them right now
for about 400 bucks.
We are a neurotech company using a device
that you can put on your head directly,
and that can allow you to
control interfaces directly
with your mind.
Back of my head, like right here,
like the dome part of the head?
We enlisted some Quicktake producers
to take NextMind's
interface for a test drive.
Comb the electrodes through
your hair to touch the scalp.
Super cool. Okay.
We decode,
directly from your visual
cortex at the back of the head,
the fluctuations of
attention that you have
in the visual cortex when
you're focusing on something.
So when you have a bunch
of objects on the screen,
those small triangles,
we call them neurotags,
basically we can not only
know that you are looking
at one of them, but also
discriminate, very quickly,
whether you wanna push
this one or this one.
Focusing on the center disc.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wow, okay.
It's like the Force, you know?
Freaky.
The current product is aimed at developers
who want to build their
own mind-controlled apps,
but it does come with a few short demos,
like a game that's controlled
part manually, part mentally.
Lead the little square guy
to the end of the level.
Help him out using your
mind to blow up enemies
and trigger mechanisms.
This is quite fun.
I blew up a enemy square.
I don't know how I feel
about staring at enemies
to blow them up, this is
promoting some kind of violence.
It's like your brain thinks
that you're able to do it
and it just does it.
So it feels, you know, like the future.
Bloomberg's beta testers
had a pretty good time
with NextMind's device overall,
but there was some disappointment
that it wasn't more, well, mind-read-y.
At the moment, you can push
a button by staring at it,
and that's about it.
It's like cool, but it's,
I just don't really know
how practical it is.
Honestly, my brain kinda hurts using this.
I'm a little afraid
about being that plugged
into a video game.
That like, literally, if my
attention goes off of it,
it would break the game, right?
But of course, it's early
days for the company
and they ultimately see
this as a first step
towards new kinds of virtual interfaces.
The thing we have in mind, really,
is to create this very
immersive experience
between your brain and the
virtual reality around you.
So I am very convinced that
in a few years from now,
we're gonna have those cool,
like augmented reality glasses,
and there's gonna be sensors on them.
And those sensors are
gonna be able to capture
some of your brain data
and allow you to basically
not have to move your hands in any way.
Just like be in direct connection
with the virtual objects surrounding you.
NextMind sits at the consumer-grade end
of the emerging BCI market,
but it's just one of many
nascent companies in a field
with a wide range of different approaches,
intended applications, and funding levels.
At the other end of the
spectrum are companies
like Elon Musk's Neuralink,
spending many millions
of dollars in an attempt
to develop truly
game-changing neural hardware.
Another such company is
Los Angeles-based Kernel.
With over $100 million dollars in funding,
founder Bryan Johnson is setting
out to read brain activity
in ways we haven't quite seen before.
The intuition people oftentimes associate
with interfaces is the
ability to control things.
That is, change a channel
on TV, skip a song,
control a drone.
We believe the most promising potential
of these interfaces is measurement.
When we have a wearable on our wrist,
we are aware of our
heartbeat and our steps
and our sleep stages.
If you went to the cardiologist,
you get your blood pressure
and EKG, cholesterol levels.
One of the only things that
we cannot consistently measure
is our brains.
We decided that the path forward
is to build new hardware.
Kernel pitches its first product,
a $50,000 headset called Flow,
as a giant leap forward for the field.
Most headsets on the market
right now use EEG technology
to get a fairly general
idea of your brain activity.
The Flow offers a much more
detailed look inside your skull.
The way it works is we
shine light into the brain.
That light goes into the brain.
Some of it bounces back and
then we use that information
to reconstruct the activity in the brain
in terms of blood oxygenation.
It's called spectroscopy.
There has been neuroimaging
going on for decades.
For example, fMRI.
They provide great images of the brain,
they've just been going
on in very large systems.
They're a few million dollars
and they are room-sized.
So what we've done is we've
shrunken a room-sized piece
of equipment into a helmet.
And so now if you say a person
on average gets their brain
scanned, say, one time every five years,
you can now imagine a
scenario with our technology,
where a person is scanning their brain
one or multiple times a day.
Johnson imagines a deluge
of big brain data coming
from these devices,
helping science to tackle
all manner of hard questions
about the workings of the mind.
It's a bit of a gamble though,
because we don't know exactly what
all that information will tell us.
You know, it'll be TBD.
We've built the technology out in front
of the science, so the science does need
to be developed.
The next step for us is
to get the first systems
in the hands of some
of the top researchers
in the entire world looking
at health and wellness
of the brain, PTSD,
concussion, meditation,
the effects of caffeine on
the brain, psychedelics.
And so it opens up all
kinds of possibilities
for mental health and
wellness, for performance,
for learning, for basically
anything that we do
with our minds.
As varied as the current crop of BCIs is,
most focus on the same thing:
reading the activity of the
brain and translating that
into useful information.
But there's another
frontier in our attempts
to access the brain that comes with
more troubling implications:
not just reading from the brain,
but actually writing to,
or directly influencing it.
In a sense, this is already being done,
with devices like deep brain stimulators,
which send electrical
impulses into the brain
to treat movement
disorders like Parkinson's.
But here at Columbia University,
neurobiologist Rafael Yuste
is proving that it's possible
to go much further,
to actually change the
brain's perception of reality.
So what we've done with mice is,
we've used a laser to measure the activity
of the visual cortex while the
mouse is looking at an image
and we train the mouse to lick
whenever he sees that image.
That's the first step.
We can also use a second laser
to activate neurons at will,
a little bit as if we were
playing the piano with the brain.
So we actually activate
the neurons that correspond
to a particular image, and
the mouse behaves exactly
the same as if he were seeing that image.
So the mouse licks,
even though we're not
showing him the image,
we're just activating these neurons.
So in a way we're sort of
taking control of his perception
and making him believe
that he's seeing something
that is not there.
Now, what can be done in animals today
could be done in humans tomorrow.
And we became concerned
that neurotechnology
should be regulated.
To that end,
Yuste and a group of fellow
neuroscientists put together
a list of guidelines that they hope
will curb the dystopian
potential of the BCI.
So we're proposing five new
human rights, neuro-rights:
the right to our mental privacy;
the right to our own identity;
the right to our own decision-making,
to prevent interference that
could change our behavior;
The fourth one has to do
with cognitive augmentation,
to prevent a situation where
people that have more resources
in certain countries,
will become augmented,
and become like super race of humans
versus the rest of the people.
There's already companies, like Neuralink,
whose purpose is to
mentally augment humans;
And the final right,
protection against bias in
artificial intelligence.
It would be terrible if we augment humans,
but actually bring into their brains
a lot of biases that are
carried out by algorithms.
Given all those potential problems,
do you think neurotechnology ends up
being a net positive or a negative?
Oh, I'm very bullish about
BCIs and neurotechnology.
I think this is gonna be a
tremendous force of progress.
Neurotechnologies are always neutral.
You can use them for good or for bad.
We always have the duty
when we come up with new technology,
to use it responsibly
and put the guard rails
so that this technology
is used to help humanity.
There's still a lot about the human mind
that we don't understand.
And even the leaders of the
field of neurotechnology
are certainly a long way
from cracking its code.
Still, they've been able
to leverage what we do know
into the beginnings of a
meaningful mind-machine link.
And it's clear the applications
will be incredibly varied,
and for some, life changing.
As to what the future holds...
I think that we're really gonna see
kind of an integration
of kind of our brains
and, you know, machines for,
I think, really kind of
a profound alteration
of our human evolution, quite frankly.
Is it possible to create,
you know, virtual memories?
Absolutely, it is.
Is it possible to have brain
to brain communication?
That's been, you know,
demonstrated by some
researchers down at Duke.
Can you upload and download
information into the brain?
I think that's a theoretic possibility.
Whether, again, that's
in 20 years or 100 years,
I think those are
possibilities going forward.
And I think just in the last century,
how we saw an explosive transition
from the Wright brothers' airplane
to kind of an F-22 Raptor,
which would have been
unimaginable 100 years ago,
we're gonna see that same evolution
with brain-computer interfaces.